la scène qui ne dure que quelques
secondes a été filmé et amélie topol
ville sous contrôle russe au ralenti en
haut à droite de l'image on aperçoit un
homme en noir emmenés par des soldats
arborant le brassard blanc des troupes
russes l'homme arrêté serait le maire de
la ville ivan fedorov peu après dans
cette ville du sud du pays des dizaines
d'habitants se sont regroupés pour
réclamer la libération de l'élu
rendez nous notre mère ce qu'entend
russe des manifestants le président
zelensky a lui aussi pris la parole
ouais c'est un maire qui défend
courageusement l'ukraine et les membres
de sa communauté au sort il s'agit de
toute évidence d'un signe de faiblesse
des envahisseurs
en ukraine l'opération spéciale russe se
transforme en une guerre d'usure dans le
sud du pays les troupes de moscou met la
pression sur la ville de miku life par
centaines d habitants partent direction
la frontière moldave
des bombardements qui vous font peur oui
c'est très dur surtout la nuit
malgré les bombardements récents et
dévastateur d'autres choisissent de
rester dans ses caves il amasse des
conserves du linge et il se prépare
aussi à la fronde it's blitz ce sont des
plaques pour gilet pare balles on les a
fait nous mêmes c'est très lourd mais ça
fonctionne côte à 500 km de là les
combats se poursuivent dans la banlieue
de kiev la nuit dernière ce quartier
résidentiel a été frappée ralenti ces
derniers jours les troupes russes ont
repris leur progression aux abords de la
capitale ukrainienne